okay so let me just give an introduction
very brief and speaker and Farid we'll
have a conversation in just a moment I
just wanted to say I was beginning to
say that Marty Feldstein was a member of
our board for about 16 years
member of the Council since 1980 and
passed away suddenly a few days ago and
we're very sorry
see him his loss it's a real loss for
the country in my view and a loss for
the council I I would like to let you
also know that at the council we have
this National Conference is made
possible by Mimi Haase Mimi is right
here Mimi ought to thank you very much
for that and I'd like to let you know
that that we have a number of people
here who have served with great
distinction on our board who are
retiring from our board I just wanted to
mention that I'm gonna thank them
publicly for their service one of them
is David Bradley who served for 10 years
where's David David right here David
thank you very much Dona Dona wryneck
also served for 10 years thank you very
much for your service and John Abizaid
is going to be he's not here now he's
gonna be our ambassador to the Saudi
Arabia so he is stepping off of our
board and VIN Weber is retiring as well
after 16 years and I wanted to thank all
of them for their service just to let
you know the board earlier today elected
new members that Alan who's the former
Commandant of the Coast Guard sana
Beschloss JJ Johnson Meghan O'Sullivan
and Rafael Reif and Dan uragan will be
on our new board members and Dan is
staying on the board he was already on
the board so thank all of them who are
here for your service and I want to
thank all of you for being part of our
membership we couldn't really survive
without your support
we get a lot of support from
philanthropist from all over the country
but very often many of our best
philanthropists are and people who are
not in Washington DC or New York they're
people from all over the country and as
I indicated earlier you are all very
important part of our our the council
the council just completed the law most
completed our capital campaign we set
out a goal to raise 150 million dollars
and we've raised just about a hundred
and eighty million dollars thank you now
the speaker applauded thank you very
much this is we talk about millions here
not billions you used to billions so the
council was set up almost a hundred
years ago really to provide a
nonpartisan dispassionate assessment of
foreign policy and to make certain that
people who want to be informed about
foreign policy are able to do so because
of the kind of research and thought
papers and discussions like this one
that we have so we are nonpartisan and
we we have people from both parties here
and from all different persuasions and
we think it contributes to the national
dialogue and I want to thank all of you
for participating in at this conference
and making this possible and thank you
for your dues your philanthropic support
all of you participated in the capital
campaign thank you capital campaign is
not completely over and so anybody that
would still be interested in
participating let us know so tonight we
have at the beginning of our conference
tonight we have a program that Richard
and arena have put together that's
terrific over the next couple days and I
would just like to introduce the people
at the beginning of it for Reed his as
you probably know the the host of Fareed
Zakaria GPS a great show on CNN he's
also a columnist for The Washington Post
editor at the Atlantic he's also been
the managing editor of Foreign Affairs
earlier in his career and most
importantly most importantly he is a
member of the board of the Council on
Foreign Relations and I will just let
and I would just say that he is a
terrific person as well and a great
friend of mine and I would say that his
interview show and his show on the TV is
the one of the few shows I actually
watch every single week so I don't miss
it and I want to thank you for giving us
informed dialogue every week and for
Reed's guests I will let him introduce
but I would just say the best thing
about Nancy Pelosi and there are many
great things is that she is from
Baltimore my hometown and her father was
mayor of Baltimore
her brother was mayor of Baltimore and
she's decided not to be mayor Baltimore
decided to take another position in
government and I'll let Fareed describe
what that position is Reid and Pelosi
thank you very much thank you thank you
David you know David is is an
extraordinary chairman of the council
and a multi-talented person he is a very
distinguished financier built this
extraordinary business and he's always
been very nice to me but then one day I
noticed I turned on the TV and there he
was with his own television show
interviewing his own guests and doing it
so well that it sort of got me a little
nervous
so madam Speaker I know you have had a
few leadership challenges and I just
want to point out to you that you may
think they're all over but you have the
unconventional one may still present
itself so if David Rubenstein offers to
renovate the Longworth office building
I would I would wonder about that
because you know maybe on your next
foreign trip you'll turn on the TV and
discover that David is presiding over
the House of Representatives but David
thank you madam Speaker Henry Kissinger
says those who need no introduction
crave them the most
but I'm I know this is not this is not
true view so I will simply say Janet
Napolitano who is also a member of the
board said to me and I think I have her
permission to quote think Nancy Pelosi
might well be the most powerful woman in
the world right now so that's my
introduction well I thank you for you so
much for the invitation to be here Davis
we call him the Pride of Baltimore
there's heart you're you're ivanishin is
well-taken though because every place I
go with the chairman of the board the
Smithsonian just hold on to your seat
David how do you have time to do all
this he said I don't play golf so many
people don't play golf but they don't
have anywhere near his accomplishments
David thank you for being the person who
you are and doing so many things in the
arts and educating Oh Duke University
well the list goes on and on so thank
you David and thank you for you thank
you Richard Haass thank you all Mimi
Haas thank you for making this weekend
possible excuse me Johnny yes and no
Mimi is saying that this sponsorship of
the weekend is in memory of Peter house
Mimi's husband late husband Peter house
he and Mimi and their entire house
family have been a source of so many
good things in our community and in
California but even in the world really
and they have done it very quietly
whether it's the arts education
University of California whether it's
sports
don't forget the boarders are on tonight
but baseball is there is there's and but
the list goes on and on and now her sons
are carrying on a tradition of great
civic engagement and philanthropy to
make the future better that's what the
Haas family has been about thank you
Mina thank you
weenie was reminding me that we've known
each other for 46 years don't tell
anybody a very long time Thank You mini
and the jest FAR's Richard Haass is
concerned we always want to know what
does Richard thing so we always tune in
to what he thinks and as far as breed is
concerned with his show I don't I don't
tune in to too much TV but it's very
soothing to be informed in a calm
intellectual way about what's going on
in the way in the world and then with
the excitement of GPS so you know it's
about the future thank you for reading
for you I just want to acknowledge
Bernard Schwartz and his wife Denise who
were here my dear dear friends and a sad
about Marty but also thanking members of
the board who are leaving and who are
here so yeah it's an interesting time
isn't it talk about the Warriors
us-canada relationships on the
basketball court so madam Speaker
pleasure pleasure to have you
Donald from says he's done with you
Dharam says that he really doesn't like
you right he said this publicly why is
it why do you think why do you get under
his skin
as I said to a reporter today analyzing
the thinking so I use the word loosely
of this plan under the President of the
United States is not what I spend my
time on I was kind of disappointed
though when we were in Normandy I just
took a big 57 House members of Democrats
and Republicans evenly divide it like
Noah's Ark one Democrat one Republican
to Normandy and in the morning I was on
on three Mitchel and she asked me
something about the president I said it
is my practice our custom everybody
respects it that when we were overseas
we never criticize
the President of the United States and
we were right there in Normandy with the
tombstones behind us in the rest so I
just wasn't going to engage in that but
I never do anyway it's our practice when
he then came on TV later in front of the
same tombstones and started saying all
this stuff it was so beyond
inappropriate I felt really sorry for
him but why do you think do you think
let me posit something do you think
there's something about you being a
strong woman who has bested him and they
in the in the shut down do you think
that has something to do with it well
there's some New Yorkers in the crowd
right but the New Yorkers told me that
women in New York and told me when he
became president they said here's what
he will do it's what he always does
first he will flatter then he will bully
and then he will sue that's just how he
that's what he does and he's true to
form true to form but our country is so
great and here we were in Normandy with
60 members 57 3 one thing or another
illness in the family
57 and it was almost 20 senators House
and Senate Democrats and Republicans as
well over there to pay our respects to
our men the courage of those who invaded
Normandy it was the biggest naval
invasion in the history of the world if
not the biggest invasion under President
I would be President Eisenhower such an
incredible thing and it was we were
there to honor our veterans many of whom
were there in their 90's many of them in
their 90's and that was their purpose to
thank them but also as a recognition of
the cooperation about with our allies
that made that success possible and we
have to remember that that was central
to how we saved civilization as well as
protected our freedom as we go forward
so this whole idea of protecting of
course our country first and foremost
that's our oaths that we take to protect
and defend
but to recognize that the collaboration
with our allies is a very very important
part of all that was then it still is
now do you think that the country is
ready for impeachment hearings here's my
thing our founders we were so blessed
for heat with our founders and not many
of us are history buffs as what many of
us are here and we do believe that
foreign policy should be nonpartisan
should stop that debate should stop at
the rivers of waters edge it doesn't
always but basically a coming back to
one guidance that our founders gave us
of all the great documents and thank God
that made the Constitution amendable it
with all the greatness of the documents
they gave us they gave us a guidance we
pluribus unum from many one they
couldn't imagine how many we would
become or how different we would be from
each other
but they knew that we had to be one and
in all that we do in my role as Speaker
of the House and I believe my most of my
colleagues subscribe to it is try to
find as much common ground as you can
strive for oneness rather than division
I don't think there's anything more
divisive we can do than to impeach a
president of the United States and so
you have to handle it with great care
has to be about the truth and the facts
to take you to whatever decision has to
be there it should by no means be done
politically you shouldn't impeach
politically or you shouldn't not engage
politically but you we must always
remember we have a responsibility for
oneness because that is the strength of
our confidence the strength of a country
always say our diversity is our strength
and our caucus we're very diverse our
diversity is our strength but our unity
is our power that's what gives us
leverage and the rest of the world that
we are the United States of America
there are several Democrats who are
running for president who are calling
for
Elizabeth Warren if one of them gets
nominated the two leaders of the
Democratic Party will be somewhat at
odds on this issue well you never know
where we'll be by the time one of them
gets nominated but it is again we are on
legislate that's our responsibility we
promised lower health care costs bigger
paychecks building the infrastructure of
America cleaner government introducing
legislation to make our government
cleaner of taking voter suppression all
of that so that's what we promise us
that we're doing with passed legislation
to that effect and we continue to do so
legislate investigate we have cause
there was an assault on our country an
assault on our democratic institution of
elections we have responsibility to get
to the bottom of that and because of the
resistance that we're getting from the
White House we must litigate so as we
investigate and litigate we'll go where
the facts take us with all due respect
to whoever may be President of the
United States it really doesn't matter
what matters are the facts it's not
about partisanship it's not Democrats
and Republicans partisanship
it's about patriotism about what we must
do and how can I say this I love the
press that or the guardians of our
democracy freedom of the press is so
important right David family however
they just have an obsession with talking
about impeachment and every time one of
my members says their foreign peace Oh
pressures on
pressures not on I respect everybody's
opinion about where they think we are on
this but I also respect the work of our
Chairman in terms of legislate
investigating litigate and we have that
responsibility to find out what happened
what sad for us is that this is a
admitted assault on our democracy every
agency of intelligence agency has high
confidence that this happened there's
proof and the rest the Muller report
subscribes to that and the President of
the United States says it's a hoax hoax
the president I said should be the one
taking the lead to look into what
happened there and instead he's saying
they could do it again that there's
something very wrong with this picture
and so in any of it
the facts the truth what's right for our
country in the most unifying way not
dividing when the Attorney General has
been held in contempt by a House
committee there are two paths you can go
down the house can vote a criminal
contempt or civil contempt in either
case I assume the Department of Justice
will not be indicted the Attorney
General you have a sergeant-at-arms in
the house you actually have a jail cell
in the base what are you going to do if
bill bar does not you know if the high
will the house hold him in criminal
contempt
well the criminal attempt contempt takes
a little bit long there's a reason they
went down the path they went down and I
have confidence in our committees I'm a
big believer in the committee system let
the members do the investigating and the
rest and make their recommendations the
it's a very sad thing the Attorney
General of the United States lied under
oath to the Congress of the United
States but that's not even why he was
held in contempt it was because of his
refusal to to obey a subpoena and so it
will take its but it's all about but
what happened was what he's not going to
the Department of Justice is not going
to enforce anything you ask of them
against the courts it's a it's the
Constitution the beautiful Constitution
of the checks and balances the heart of
the matter separation of powers they
don't the courts will determine that and
a disagreement between the executive the
legislative which is the first branch of
government the legislative and the
executive branch and so we're going to
the courts and we think we have a good
case we won the first two cases which
were unequivocal about there's no
question that the Congress has oversight
responsibilities and should have access
to the information article three
actually no you know article three of
the articles of impeachment for Richard
Nixon were that he refused to obey
impeachment of the subpoenas of the
House of Representatives but it's very
it's very hard to understand how the
Republicans in Congress have no support
for the institution in which they serve
to support and defend the Constitution
and the rights of the House of
Representative
well the Congress House and Senate as
well as of the assault on our elections
we don't know how long that will last
but as more information unfolds we hope
to get to the to the bottom of it yeah
let's turn to foreign policy the
Secretary of State has just said thank
you I don't I wouldn't be doing my job
if I didn't ask some of those questions
the Secretary of State says that the
attacks on the two tankers in the around
the Straits of Hormuz were Iranian but
done by the Iranian government do you
think that we are in for a possible
military confrontation between the
United States and Iran well I certainly
hope not but for people of a certain age
or students of history Straits of Hormuz
gives you chills right right oh my
goodness but I do think that the
Secretary has not offered any proof of
this he's just said what he said and
it's not unbelievable that a country
might exercise its leverage and here the
Prime Minister of Japan is in if he's
not still there he was there yesterday
are they in um in Iran and and so
we'll see what that is but we have
absolutely no appetite for going to war
or to be provocative to create
situations that might evoke responses
where mistakes could be made you know
it's one country's exercised their
leverage they threatened they this or
that but there could be mistakes made
and that's a very dangerous thing in I'm
here
we were up almost all night with our
appropriations bill but at the same time
the during the night the defense the
Armed Services Committee was writing the
defense bill and in the defense bill
which they ended at 7:00 o'clock this
morning they put in there nothing in the
bill would be considered an
authorization of use of military force
against Iran that the administration
would try to use some authorities that
are frankly non-existent but we have to
the American people have no appetite for
a for a war with Iran they may I don't
think the president does the president
wasn't for the war in Iraq as you know
and so I think I think this board before
he was against it I think he changed his
mind on it a little well as I say I
can't but I'm too busy to be worrying
about what if and when what he did but
he tells me all the time I was against
the war in Iraq so that was why I was
what he said but it is this is a very
dangerous situation if I just made just
go back a little bit what is his
motivation what is their motivation to
be provocative with the Iranians why did
the president turn his back on the
Iranian nuclear agreement this was an
agreement that was masterful it was a
diplomatic virtuosity
virtuoso performance on the Secretary of
State John Kerry and Hillary before him
others involved at all of these
countries Russia and China never would
do any sanctions on Iran never they
wouldn't because it
could be a source of fundamentalist
activity in their regions in both China
and so they always look the other way
with Iranian this or that so that they
that they would be part of this
agreement so from a diplomatic
standpoint it was remarkable the
countries that came together from a
nuclear standpoint of the letter from
the among other things but I just spot
one letter from the nuclear physicist
some of them Nobel laureates and and all
of this wrote that this bill should be
the template template for nuclear
agreement non-proliferation agreements
should be the template monies that the
Secretary of Energy knows this stuff so
well communicating with the Iranians so
they understood that he understood and
the others as well so so when we voted
for that and the Congress who voted to
support the President on that it was
having heard from all of the ambassadors
from these countries coming in saying
what their commitment wasn't it was a
remarkable achievement and it really you
have to wonder why if you do not want
Iran to have a nuclear weapon and then
you said well they could have a nuclear
weapon in ten years under this agreement
when was that the agreement they could
have one in one year so what's the
what's the logic except some other issue
that it was negotiated by President
Obama and we had so many not national
security experts whether they were
ambassadors generals Admirals and all
the rest supporting of the agreement as
well so it had official diplomatic
national security Technol nuclear etc a
support along the way so why so then he
comes in and does undoes that and you
know in flames the u.s. Iran issue why
what is the what is the purpose
and then too I'm not going to accuse
anybody of instigating anything but for
not having a policy that would smooth
the waters so to speak so again I don't
I think he probably knows there's no
appetite for war among the American
people
and I myself very much was against the
war in Iraq so you know I see the
consequences of and it's very sad you
just came back as I said from Normandy
but before Normandy around a president's
weekend we were there for the took a big
delegation bipartisan to the Munich
conference and then following that we
went to Brussels then following that
which Mitch McConnell was invited in a
bipartisan way Secretary General of the
NATO to give a joint address a to the
Congress of the United States never
happened before on the 70th anniversary
of NATO I bring all of that up because
in all of that so many foreign ministers
came to that nerve and all of those
meetings in the rest there's real fear
concern on the part of our allies as to
what our path is what is their mission
what what what is there a plan how do
how does America how does America intend
to lead the greatest country that ever
existed in history of the world people
look to us for leadership and as
recently as this weekend we could see
the concern that our allies have about
the path to Berlin including visa B Iran
let me ask you about trade the president
has invoked national security as a
reason to threaten or impose tariffs on
a variety of countries the the law that
he's invoking is essentially a cold war
law which was meant to be about you know
protecting American steel industry in
the geopolitical competition with the
Soviet Union he's using it for Japanese
SUVs for Canadian aluminum is the
president subverting the law in
threatening these tariffs
well that law that you reference is a
law that was to use that authority
against our enemies enemies is the word
in the law against our enemies and so so
I don't want to be political here this
isn't a political agreement but just
understand this mother report comes out
tariffs on Mexico
it's a diversionary tactic in the
campaign the president had two big
things that he ran on his positive
agenda anti immigration an anti trade
that's his agenda so I mean I heard
heard a little Merkel and in a unit at
the speech that she gave to leaders who
were gathered there to say I don't know
it's a national security issue for
German cars but many of which are made
in South Carolina to be sold in the
United States and what so so the trade
issue is a red meat issue for his base
and I'll tell you this I have been
fighting China on trade for 30 years
since gentlemen square of June 4th we
observed the 30th anniversary of the
massacre and see an immense square so
sad and now you see what's happening
Hong Kong's or not it's very sad as well
but in the course of that time we had 30
years ago well I didn't start except one
more year later 29 when we started
legislating about what had happened
there
29 years the trade deficit was fine with
China was five billion dollars a year
five billion dollars a year here I'm a
brand-new member of Congress David that
sounded like all the money in the world
five billion dollars we could free the
prisoners up Tiananmen gainax market
access for our product stops a theft of
our the piracy of our intellectual
property and stop their proliferating of
weapons technology and delivery system
missiles sales to rogue countries five
billion dollars well everybody said no
and do with that you can't use trade but
Baba we
one in the house the Senate all the time
but we could never override a veto of
President Bush or President Clinton so
you just wait and see it's all going to
work itself out
now the trade deficit with China is more
than five billion dollars a week now I
bring that up because China has a trade
deficit with the EU as well first they
were using our money to buy from the EU
so the EU was making nice-nice with the
China and then they did what they do
they turned on them and started having a
trade surplus with the EU so the perfect
thing would be if you're going to be
China that you would use maximum
leverage join with the EU and the US -
state of China it's over you cannot
exploit this trade relation you must
abide by the rules of the WTO if you are
going to be a member of the WTO and have
the advantages but where did the
president do instead he put tariffs on
the EU and I thought that was messing
that up and not the right route to go so
that but understand I think that the
trade issue was the trade representative
is fabulous he were working very closely
with him on the Mexico us-canada
whatever it's called is it now after
NAFTA and after 2.0 whatever you want to
call it we hope that we could be on a
path to yes for that but in other ways
it's it's why would he put tariffs
certain tariffs on Mexico right when
we're about to come to some writing of
an agreement except to divert attention
from the Mullen report let me ask you
though about presidential power is there
a kind of usurpation of congressional
authority since 1976 when Congress
declared a national emergency act Gerald
Ford signed it there have been 50
presidents have declared 59 emergencies
32 are still in place we still have
national emergencies in place about
Macedonia by Lebanon about the Iran
hostage crisis is it time for Congress
to start much more seriously overseeing
the this kind of executive
usurpations of power yeah I think
Congress was on were accomplices and
some of these things but we're dealing
with presidents with whom we had shared
values and to give the president the
facility to do what he needed or
hopefully one day she needed to do but
the but it has gone too far
and you it's a national emergency it's
one thing but if it's to declare a
national emergency that doesn't exist
isn't as a exploitation of an
opportunity that shouldn't be taken
taking place he's doing it with Saudi
arms sales there is a there is an
end-run around Congress is there
something you you intend to do to
prevent that or to counter it we have a
no Congress will vote against the arms
sales to Saudi Arabia and the other
countries to it's unfortunate that the
Emirates and Jordan countries that had
nothing to do with Yemen or to do with
Khashoggi or do with other things are
caught in that but it is what we have to
address so there will be a vote to
remove any authority to make those sales
to Saudi Arabia but there's something
more about Saudi Arabia and that is this
is nuclear technology that he is
transferring to Saudi Arabia so it runs
into other acts of Congress that he must
that cannot be ignored so this is going
to be a quite a discussion and you have
to wonder what's with Saudi Arabia why
of all the countries in the world the
President of the United States chooses
his first country to visit Saudi Arabia
President Bush and President Clinton for
all the presidents since Reagan went to
either Canada or Mexico there are plenty
other allies that this president could
have visited what was the purpose of
giving so much face just Saudi Arabia
follow the money what's going on here
and there is a question of who is
financially benefiting from the nuclear
part of the sales to Saudi Arabia so
this is something that we will fight and
we'll have bipartisan support define
good
it's about Yemen you know we already had
that vote he vetoed it but it was a
strong bipartisan vote in the Congress
and so the case against Saudi Arabia in
terms of Yemen in terms of khashoggi in
terms of so much that they should not be
receiving this kind of what these
weapons sales is very strongly
bipartisan in the Congress well
president from be able to build his wall
using Defense Department monies in oh
the bill that injured at 7:00 a.m.
prohibits that from happening but we're
also in the courts and we we won in one
of the courts that said you can't use
defense money for that purpose but again
you go to court you never know about the
course it depends on the venue and the
judge and the rest so we'll continue to
make that case and it but the decision
was the Congress of the United States
has the authority to appropriate funds
and that's the law that's the
Constitution it's right there in the
second amendment but it's also in the
court decision so always think of it the
controversies the Constitution the
Congress the courts and that's the path
that we're taking with that the asylum
system does seem to be overwhelmed if
not broken when you have these many
people presenting themselves at the
border I know I'm sure you don't like
what President Trump is doing but what
surely the Democrats also have a
responsibility to come up with some fix
that would work well we have to have
comprehensive immigration reform the
Senate voted that in a very bipartisan
way a few years ago but the House
Speaker then would not bring it to the
floor but we have to have a
comprehensive immigration reform on the
question of asylum what the evangelical
community has been very
positive on immigration and they
testified in one of our before we won
the majority we had I guess you'd call
it a rump hearing but a hearing it which
we we had it you'll know exactly when
because it was when the president had
that Muslim ban and we had a big hearing
with the diplomats coming in military
people coming in everybody coming in and
saying this was wrong it was wrong it
was wrong
including evangelicals and he been
Jellico's at that hearing stated when I
say in bed jealous I don't mean one
person I mean the representative for the
American Association of Evangelicals
said the following the United States
refugee resettlement program is the
crown jewel of American humanitarianism
the crown jewel we have a responsibility
as all countries do as far as refugees
are concerned in terms of what we the
situation we see now that's a big number
there but a small number compared to
what other countries have taken in in
terms of refugees that you know better
than any of us in in terms of Syria and
other safety valves for refugees coming
into countries but here's this thing we
have to look at it comprehensively the
northern triangle countries there are we
have in our legislation funds to assist
there to try to alleviate the causes for
the departures of these people from
those countries we have to do it in a
way that goes directly to the people or
to the NGOs and the rest because there's
corruption wherever there's a lot of
money going into a situation like that
these people are leaving because they
have no choice they'll either be killed
or their children will be forced to join
a gang or be killed and the rest of that
that's the only reason somebody would
take the chance to cross a desert to try
to come to our country and of course
when they come here they want economic
opportunity that's not what the asylum
says purpose is but it's about fear of
well-founded fear of persecution dance
whatever
in their country so we've got to try to
keep people home by using the
appropriated funds appropriately at the
border we have to have more funds which
we have appropriate and giving them
administration for more judges to
facilitate the process not you don't
qualify you go back that's just the way
it is but not to have this tremendous
backlog the humanitarian needs are great
and we have bipartisan agreement on much
of the humanitarian needs that are there
but so that is in terms of addressing
the humanitarian crisis that is there
but the refugee resettlement issue the
refugee issue has to be part of
comprehensive immigration reform I'm
going to open it up to the questions
before I do I'm gonna ask you one last
question which is if you were to give
advice to some of the candidates who
were running for the Democratic primary
as somebody again who seems to have
handled President Trump very well what
would you tell them what is the advice
you would give them about how to how to
run against Donald from forget about him
just talk about what you have to offer
everybody knows the situation that
existed in the White House I my whole
thing well I tell everybody my
candidates for Congress and the rest and
that's I think one of the reasons we won
in 2018 it said don't even mention his
name this is about what you have to
offer people are concerned about health
care in America they're concerned about
the stagnation of their wages they're
concerned and and skeptical about even
government operate working for them
rather than for the special interest so
just talk about what you have to offer
so I would say to them and as I say to
these presidentials show them your why
what is your vision why are you running
show them your your knowledge what do
you know that is it climate changes it
at the
security what is your what is your real
y-you know what motivates you to run and
think that you will be the best
president not your why your what what do
you know and what judgements can you
demonstrate by the knowledge that you
have how are you going to get it done
vision knowledge strategic thinking show
them all of that because that's what a
leader has to demonstrate but none of it
counts for anything unless you connect
with them heart to heart about your
authenticity about the United States of
America and your connection to their
hopes and dreams aspirations and
apprehensions the fears that they have
authenticity is everything in terms of
how they make a judgement about the they
figure we're all about the greatness of
America they don't know I mean they want
to see a demonstration of knowledge and
therefore judgment want plans
everybody's got plans go to my website
but the connection the connection is the
most important thing so I would just
tell them why you're running what you
care about how you intend to make it
happen to improve their lives as you ask
them about him you could talk about a
level of integrity that you would bring
to the White House but I wouldn't I
really wouldn't go there so much how to
deal with him because you see what he
does is he projects like when he says
Nancy's a mess that means he's a mess
when he says Nancy's nervous that means
he's nerd he's always projected he's
disowning his own yeah somebody doesn't
have stammer it's always about him he's
always talking about himself no matter
who the subject of the sentences it's
always about him I mean I have people I
mean really there has to be an
intervention here but that's it I don't
recommend that any candidate for
president
well the thing is is that I respect the
office of President of the United States
sometimes I think I respect it more than
the person holding the office right now
I respect the office of president I
respect the people who voted for Donald
Trump for president they have their
fears or apprehensions their hopes he
gave them reason to thing I also know
that he did you know he what is the one
bill he's passed in Congress tax breaks
to give a 83 percent of the bill of the
tax benefits the top one percent that's
not about the people who voted for him
so you do have to get to a place to talk
about policy and make a contrast but
when there when you are so that part of
it is the is what is the excitement of a
campaign what are your policies how are
you different differentiate how would
you do something better it's not about
the politics of personal destruction and
how I'm going to make you look bad
because I'm going to call your name oh
really it in terms of the president and
the biggest contrast will be to be about
policy to be about integrity and not to
be worried about any who can be more
clever in characterizing the current
occupant of the White House and let me
just say one more thing because you
introduce you create callers so many
things governor secretary Madam
President of the University of
California very snow Pollock Janet
Napolitano racism that and she said on
the most powerful more and I I don't let
Sarah subscribe to that but it's a very
sad thing for me because I certainly
thought that at this point we would have
a woman president of the United States
every time I'm introduced as the most
powerful I think boohoo boohoo
but seventeen months from now we'll have
a new president of the United States all
right
[Applause]
now we always say this but I will
actually exercise my powers here please
no speeches
no no long-winded comments we're in the
hope that we can get more people's
questions answered if you can raise your
hands identify yourself and ask a brief
question to the speaker that would be
wonderful
no speeches disguised as questions yeah
your no speeches disguised and that it
never happens on in the House of
Representatives I'm sure my name is
Roger Parkinson this may be off the
formulations policy but you assert us in
a Congress with a number of Republican
speakers of the house I wonder if you
could give us a brief thumbnail
evaluation or description or of the
difference republican speakers that have
been there since you've been there how
are they similar and how are they
different
well I would only say that I served
because when I came there we had
Democratic speakers and the contrast
between them and the Republicans was
always vast in terms of love of the
institution respectful of the fact that
you're the speaker of the whole house so
the first Republican I served with was
Dennis Hastert and he really wasn't the
speaker he was sort of the front person
Tom DeLay really ran the show there so
there wasn't a strong speakership
they're more personable amiable as John
Boehner but see they couldn't keep their
caucus together the way he would come to
meetings and said yes we'll do this or
that and then not be able to do it so it
was really not about the speaker so much
just but the Republican caucus had
become with the cheap party and the rest
of that and
you
challenged because
rogue my concern about them 20 years ago
and now is that their proliferators when
we were there they wanted to be off the
UM though that has different names used
to be rogue states and it was countries
of concern there's all the name they
want to be off that list so they could
have advantages in our relationship and
we said well you've got to stop selling
these weapons they said you do it for
the money we'll sell the missiles to you
we already do it for the money
well they have a geopolitical agenda as
well but I do maintain that when they
are doing their tests and stuff it's
their dog and pony show for selling that
stuff to bad actors about in terms of
other countries so I keep saying to the
administration be careful of them as it
proliferators and because if they use a
weapon it's got a return address they're
dead right they still you know and we
would have our anytime our actions to
prevent something from hitting us but
they shouldn't start that but who they
sell to and maybe not a intercontinental
missile but in terms of other
technologies is a danger danger to the
world so I would say this has to be
multilateral everything that is
multilateral is really much more
effective anyway and they have to know
that there's a global intervention into
as to what they are doing and that
they're not going to get praised this
guy for being good guys I'm the
president of United States loves I'm not
I'm in the interest of time I'm not
going on to what you see when you go to
North Korea but it's that was 20 years
ago so maybe things have improved
somewhat in terms of starvation in a
country that advocates self-reliance as
their mantra but but I thank you for
your question it's a this is because
this is really hopefully I would like to
think the remaining nuclear threat in
terms of proliferation but that would be
probably too optimistic but nonetheless
a very significant
and proliferation I mentioned as one of
the pillars of our security when we
talked about that is the deterrence of
it all that's a that's so essential and
America has to be preeminent and all
that that's why I'm disappointed what
the President did in terms of of Iran
since that was the last question may I
thank you for reading let me just say
I'm so happy to be here the first time I
came here Pete Peterson interviewed me
and I loved him so much
you know such a darling man yesterday
couple of days ago participated in his
fiscal conference in Washington DC so
I'm very honored to be my families
they're excited that I'm being
interviewed by Fareed Zakaria as he was
a future let me give you one thing to
toss in because you had said to me that
you like one element of the show which
was the book of the week and you've
actually in the past kind enough to send
me books to read one of which I did
recommend let me hand the book of the
week recommendation over to you this
week what what book would you recommend
that you've recently read that you think
people would profit from well I'm gonna
just tell you what I sent to read
because it was because the writer is
Italian so that's it I'm there to echo
but he wrote a book called the island of
the day before which was enjoyable and
the I live said line you're on this ship
is here here if it's a different day and
it's about longitude you enter longitude
longitude was the powerplay of the Age
of Discovery if you could tell latitude
by the Stars but if you could tell
longitude and be able to return to where
you planted a flag that was a big deal
so I sent free two books one was the
island of the day before which is a
novel and the other one is longitude
about how finally longitude was able to
be determined and maintained on a ship
the salty seas and the rest of that if
that doesn't really turn you on for a
complete change of total pace of one
thing I was reading over recently was
something called Searcy which is about
Greek mythology so that's that's to get
your mind off of your day job but let me
just say this because I come here I
mentioned when I came before as a house
Democratic leader for the first time
with Peterson and the Council of Foreign
Relations it was a big honor at this
time I'd come as Speaker of the House in
the house that has so many more women
members and it's such an honor for us as
we in this Congress we will observe the
100th anniversary of women receiving the
right to vote fighting for marching for
it not not getting it when when when
they vote came forth it said women given
the right to vote not given not given at
all that's a whole other subject but but
now in the Congress and this Congress
that will celebrate the hundredth
anniversary of women having the right to
vote we have a hundred and we have a
hundred and five members women members
of Congress first time we've gone over a
hundred ninety-one of them are Democrats
but in any event I find that to be the
most wholesome advance that we can make
the more women in politics and in
government I think the more wholesome
that all is so I encourage all women to
know their power get out there and run
for office or help others do so and
again to make the difference and to
again to strive in a way that has
transparency so people know what's going
on bipartisanship to the extent that you
can achieve it and unifying it pluribus
unum as our founders intended so thank
you for the opportunity
have you been up